Dr Hank pin played by Michael Douglas
develops a suit that can shrink a human
the whole point of thatman then is to
stop the all important Tech from getting
into the wrong hands but it does a Hydra
agent named Mitchell Carson fleas pin
Technologies with some yellow jacket
particles and runs off to Parts Unknown
where does he go and how does he use
yellow jacket particles to advance his
own agenda audiences never find out
because neither of the sequels Antman
and the WASP nor Antman in the WASP
Quantum Mania follow up on Caron when
confronted with this lack of plot
development Antman director pton Reed
explained the unresolved Cliffhanger he
told Cinema Blend there was a sequence
where Antman has an encounter with him
but then for a couple reasons I felt
like maybe we should leave those
particles out there